[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to what is
it about a good TV show intro that just
gets you hyped up it's almost a dying
art a lot shows we'll just show a title
card a live even that and be done with
it but with those that know the
importance of it a lot of work is put in
the intro to a show is like a trailer
for your product and years of
advertising have made it clear that
that's pretty damn essential from the
music to the visuals to the explanation
of what you're about to see it has to be
the best representation you can put out
there and we're going to look at the
best of them here today now there are a
few limitations here first off I'm only
doing American shows the reason well if
we include Japan in their Tait open I'm
also not just going for the catchiest
theme and it has to be more than just
some clips thrown together a lot of it
has to be created for the opening the
song the visuals and just how much it
gets you hyped up to see the show with
that said let's take a look and see
which eleven incorporated these
qualities the most why 11 because I like
to go one step beyond so sit back and
enjoy the top 11 best TV show intro
[Music]
number one
Jonny Quest the real adventures a
clipper will send up to the 60s cartoon
this 90s reboot did a good job at
keeping the retro feel while also
updating it with some modern touches
true it does seem rather simplistic just
flying through a CG backdrop of green
lines while images from the show play
but again it's how uniquely they display
them if it was only clips edited
together it wouldn't be as interesting
but here flying past them in a seemingly
interactive landscape it suddenly brings
everything to life
the music also does great building up
the adrenaline just listen to those
opening notes hell yeah it's like a mix
between terminator and Batman it's just
the right combination of 90s cheese and
really kind of eighties cheese baby
shows had this kind of technology and
music at the time it probably looked
very similar the only thing that bothers
me is unlike Batman where it's reveal
what it is you've been flying through
during the credits this one tries to do
so too
but what the hell is it was it a virtual
reality petri dish is it a canyon if
wily coyote was in the matrix it just
looks like lasered scrambled eggs behind
your logo what does that have to do with
anything now well it's still pretty cool
intro to get you prepared for some
really cool adventure number 10
[Music]
jack-of-all-trades how did I never hear
of this show this is totally off the
wall in the vein of the enjoyably corny
escapades of Hercules and Xena Warrior
Princess this was an adventure series
said in the 19th century starring Bruce
Campbell as a kind of zorro / Scarlet
Pimpernel action hero it's as silly as
it sounds and it doesn't hide it in the
least
while this intro does show some clips
from the show its effort in staging a
fully choreographed musical number more
than bass up for it's like something out
of a Disney production hell even Disney
won quite go this silly but that's part
of what makes it so unique and bizarre
[Music]
look at everybody they are totally
owning how ridiculous this all is but it
looks like they're having such a great
time we kind of get sucked in right
along with them I don't know who thought
this up but you don't see many
live-action intros quite like this
although maybe for a reason seeing how -
I lasted two seasons but it's still
amazingly fun it's clearly flamed by its
own rules and cheerfully asking us to
join it
[Music]
number not
pee-wee's Playhouse this intro has a
little bit of everything
live-action puppet stop-motion and of
course our terrifying Grandmaster a
batshit insanity what's so funny about
this intro is not only how long it is
ranking in at two and a half minutes
where most show intros only about 30
seconds but the first half is
surprisingly laid-back it's almost like
a soothing vacation in a fantasy land
[Music]
this of course offsets the rest of the
segment which is loud fast pace and
totally crazy
adding to the random madness is the fact
that Cindy whopper is the singer of the
song yeah not even kidding
they got Cindy Lauper to do that noise
it makes no fucking sense
but that's also part of what's so fun
about it it's surreal energized and will
make you question what the hell you
drank today it's crazy fun as only
pee-wee Herman can supply
[Music]
number 8 Bucky O'Hare this is another
show it didn't really see much of
growing up but by god I wish I did I
mean I get the basic some sort of space
bunny stopping evil toads and taking
over the universe justifiably silly
enough but Jesus Christ look at all this
it's like Mad Max furry Road it's just a
rush of violence and fucking crazy
imagery look at how fast it goes there's
no way to keep track of all of it hence
you'd have to come back to the show just
to see what you missed getting blowed up
in the opening you practically have to
pause it it goes so fast and I swear to
god that's Chris Rock's voice doing the
same biggity it's not even really that
long but when you're done you feel like
you've gone through a lot you feel like
you survived while those Tank Girl
earthworm jim resident evil apocalypses
with a bunny witch yeah we still fin to
any of those definitely an intro to get
whatever color your alien blood is
pumping
number seven
[Music]
x-men that's not gonna be awesome guitar
work there's just something to how grand
and huge the imagery is it really looks
like something out of those classic 80s
Marvel Comics flying through space laser
beams everywhere a strange obsession
with the color yellow
it still feels hue even the letter X
it's such a cool-looking letter that's
why they draw it in the middle of the
ocean and have it explode because it's a
letter X and that's it's cool seeing
their names fly by each character as
they display their powers and fight off
evildoers how can not get excited for
this I should also include the Japanese
intro for the show which is even more me
and yeah I know what you're thinking
wait I thought you said no Japanese
titles well yeah it turns out it was so
good that they actually put at the end
of the American end credits so it counts
how can you not get the chills every
time you hear that Bell
it's the bill that says your homework is
done even if it's not there is only X
midnight we have that cool letter
exploding in the ocean your ass is ours
ending with an army of enemies rushing
toward an army of Heroes with civilians
panicking in the middle how can this not
get you jacked up that's a man is a
kick-ass show
now you know number six
[Music]
Fresh Prince of bel-air okay this might
not be as it at they can say trauma or
action but come on who doesn't know
every lyric to this intro and sing along
whenever it's mentioned it's a perfect
representation of the show it's silly
it's over-the-top it's kid friendly but
not insulting Lee so it's colorful it's
creative and it's a complete time
capsule to the late 80s and early 90s
[Music]
but the funny thing is just like
demolition man engulfing it in its time
period surprisingly made it more
timeless it is so in-your-face and
unapologetic in its goofiness that it
gives it its own sense of fun that
people can laugh and enjoy at anytime
you can be a grown adult or a little kid
and still get the same amount of joy
from this one of the few instances of a
TV intro being both dated and timeless
all at the same time now this is a story
number by the twilight zone / the outer
limits not only do both of these shows
have similar premises but they also have
the same goal with their intro to make
you feel like you're being teleported
and from very simple means they pull it
off
who doesn't know those famous four notes
from the Twilight Zone help anytime
something weird happens people still
hummed those four notes peanuts in the
opening have never been that great but
they were so surreal and matched Rod
Serling's brilliant writing and
narration despite how fake it look you
really felt like you were entering a
different realm of reality almost like
you were being put in a trance you
unlock this door with the key of
imagination you're moving into a land of
both shadow and substance of things and
ideas you've just crossed over into the
twilight zone Outer Limits is even more
minimal in its approach all you're
looking at most of the time is just a
line but again the writing and the tones
suck you into a different world only
this time it seems a bit more like a
hostage situation you're under the
control of whoever is talking to you on
the television set there is nothing
wrong with your television set we are
controlling transmission for the next
hour sit quietly and we will control all
that you see in here imagine seeing this
for the first time back then it would
probably catch you a little off your
guard you are about to experience the
awe and mystery which reaches from the
inner mind to the outer limit
wow these are the most eloquent and
abstract errors I've ever seen both know
how to take you into an altered state of
being and each one is still remembered
years later for doing it so well it was
the perfect tone to an uncomfortable
night of dimension Joey
[Music]
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles yeah you
know I had to put this one on there only
an intro this awesome could get you so
pumped for something as crazily titled
as Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
the animation here is so good the
shadows the light particles the motion
it makes something so silly seem
incredibly bannocks while not forgetting
to include the silly stuff to a few
seasons later they changed up the intro
and well not bad and you could
definitely argue it more adequately fit
the silly tone he wasn't merely half as
good this just felt like an action
thrill ride it's still hard for me not
to go apeshit whenever I hear that
opening guitar everybody looks amazing
in it everybody moves amazing in it and
I still don't know how they make that
weird high-pitched sound when they say
heroes in a half-shell how do you
duplicate that I don't know if you can
it's just so perfectly bizarre the city
looks fantastic the angles are beyond
cool the song is catchy as all royal
hell even if you're not a turtle fan
nobody can deny the awesomeness of this
opening its Cowabunga tastico so man
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
by far the best part of any thundercats
episode was always the intro and don't
get me wrong i'm mostly indifferent to
the show I don't love it I don't hate it
but even the most die-hard fans can tell
the difference between the incredible
opening animation and the downgraded
animation of the rest of the show it's
impossible not to get excited for this I
mean look at that imagery swords lasers
explosions people running at the speed
of light monsters staring off into the
distance the fact that snarf only gets
one second of screen time it does
everything right
the song and it's guitar work is pure
80s awesomeness
every time you say thunder thunder
thunder you can't help but get more
energized with every breath it's a word
you can't say three times without
getting more excited
thunder thunder thunder city you can't
do it look at how the camera follows
them I mean yeah I know there's
technically no camera following them but
the way it's animated it feels like
there is you feel like you're running
right along with chitara you feel like
you're doing flips with lion-o it's a
freaking blast it keeps the energy high
and the excitement building what else
can you say but
[Music]
[Applause]
number two
[Music]
Tales from the Crypt you might think
it's weird I'm putting this so high up
when really it seems like a glorified
house tour but literally from the first
frame this intro is dripping with gothic
amazingness look at the size and scale
of it all look at the attention to
detail just feel the atmosphere losing
through every second of film it doesn't
need characters writing or even any
explanation it's just a gothic tour with
some gothic imagery the Lightning the
cobwebs the creaking doors the different
colors of shadow yeah there's actually
different colors of shadow here going
from blue to brown to orange to red it
surprisingly films the darkness and
Technicolor the music is pitch perfect
composer Danny Elfman writes of both
kind of silly but also kind of creepy
theme that carries the bump tastic size
of any epic ghost story
[Music]
they do so much by doing nothing but
showing a house really think about that
think about how huge creative and critic
they come off simply by showing you this
place it's amazing what they can do with
such a simple concept and of course it's
all building up to our big payoff and
then there's nothing but terrible puns
from there it's your old pal the big
scare Hoonah well-played even if you
thought the show was hit and miss the
introduction always made you happy and
clicked on the channel it's dark
brooding and has just the right amount
of goofy creep it's dead on arrival in
the best way possible and number one TV
show intro is this intro what the hell
can I say about it it's just amazing
every frame could be hung on a wall
every image is something insane and
awesome and when you run it all together
it's literally and figuratively a
rollercoaster no honestly they put you
on a roller coaster in the open
look at how much for throwing at you
it's an onslaught of creativity both
visually and musically with once again
Danny Elfman doing the music it doesn't
it sound fucking great
[Music]
but you itself was just as strange not
really super funny but not really super
disappointing either it's kind of its
own weird thing it was an excuse to be
extremely odd gross and desire and the
intro perfectly represented that it's so
enjoyed how totally off-the-wall and
nuts it was that you wanted to admire
its confidence rather than question its
motives the show didn't make a whole lot
of sense but with an opening like this
you didn't care you just got that this
was the kind of oddities this show was
constantly gonna give you and enjoy
giving and it made no apologies for it
yeah it sucks you in on this incredible
descent into both a fantasy and a
nightmare both at the same time
first opening is good and catches the
crazy spirit of the show the second one
is where shit really gets off the chain
just look at this all they have to do is
animate him coming up from the ground
but even that's done to an absolute
extreme watch it in slow-mo it's amazing
the motion and detail they put into it
and all in such an incredible speed hold
my hands up while watching this it's
such a rush
there's one moment where they even
capture free-falling look at this I
don't know how they do it but they
create the same sensation of going over
a hill on a roller coaster that they do
going into this tent
I've never seen an opening of a show do
that there's a damn incredible talent
Network into 30 seconds when it's done
you feel like you have to take a breath
it's just incredible
it's the ultimate crazy unbelievably
surreal ride any show that wants to get
you excited for should have God bless
every batshit crazy moment of it
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]